[Music]
mercy has figured out how to break
edgar's brain
again
what were you doing peggy
you're man
you have to sound like a man
one thing in japan is that there's a lot
of like scandinavian stuff everywhere
like scandinavian design scandinavian
swedish house but this is too
far we do not use these in scandinavia
no
i forbid you to sell this japan
in sweden we always have mini baskets
you always see
i've never heard of
but sweden let's go
why is there sweden everywhere
what is happening no constance it means
somewhere and then over there enfold
why
okay
is this a swedish brand it must be
clunking oh it is made in sweden never
mind
look at these
look at these dudes
all right you're gonna die
oh my god go down
oh he's stuck to the
ice please
oh no
okay so marcio wants this duck but it's
random which one you get
so we both got one i got one to help out
i guess wait
it's a mushroom
i'm not gonna cheat like you did
oh wait
what
that one's cute
well we're gonna have all of them
before you get your catch yet
are they two
yes
good trying
[Music]
okay why is this happening
it's all happening here
[Music]
hello
we're going somewhere secret marching
has a secret what's your secret margin
i'm excited i don't know what this is
emma's in the back
[Music]
woods
squirrel farm i see a golf course what
the hell are we going golfing
where are we going
i don't know
i have no idea
edo tokyo open air architectural museum
okay
yeah
actually you're not great you guys
playing then
they're spraying us with green is this
good kind of spray
it's a lot of mush
oh so cool that is nice actually
oh there they are
hey
do you like them no
me neither
wait so this is our oldest houses
okay cool
this is some weird ghibli looking house
are we entering this one
i feel like we're just snooping in
people's homes
oh my god that bath is so tiny
how do you even fit there
you need precision for this toilet
so i can't touch this
i can't touch that
i can't touch that
i can't touch that does that mean i can
so they move all these houses to this
area
what
whoa look at this
damn
and you can get sausages
nekopanchi
cat punch
love it look at this
we decided to eat here because it looks
amazing
and i got a coffee flow
genius
absolutely
genius um
he got really hot out of nowhere
god damn that's a lot of eyes girl
give it yeah
it's a little paw
so cute
i'm doing
terrible it's like a neighborhood of
unique houses so they either
rebuilt or move them over here
all in one place it's really
something
what
what
you guys want to cook something yeah
whoa what a tail
what
so pretty
uh
that's disgusting
this is a farmhouse
oh yes
[Music]
i could leave her
don't know where they would keep the
wi-fi but
you're insane
i'm australian by the way that's why
there you go oh why would you do
the skin this fine
it's right next to me
this is my friend it's good yeah
the new brain makes you look cool cicada
now you find as many as you can oh i get
it now emma was telling us about this
i'm like what do you do with the skin
i don't know if other other australians
do you also do this
no
oh it's gone
that is so gross
that's amazing
so you can enter oh you can
[Music]
whoa
that's awesome this is amazing
[Music]
the other ones were cool but this is
awesome
even the back alley
so cool
so this would be a flower shop
back in the good old days
so this would be a stationary store
[Music]
get your pens
pencils
wow
so many
this is sake shop i think soy sauce
never mind
[Music]
so this is the bathhouse
this is so cool
living in life
hell yeah
love the art
make yourself pretty
in the mirror oh there was a crab
samurai
see
the good old days
they still have bath houses in tokyo or
everywhere but
i've never actually been in one
i love this area
i would definitely recommend checking it
out super cool way to see like
historical japan
architecture love it it feels magical
walking around here too like i know i
said it but it seems like a ghibli movie
nice hat marzian
[Music]
we're back home
[Music]
to this little squirrel
hello
that was so good
had such a good time
now i'm gonna study
and then oh yes big stretch let's go
sorry i just wanted to stay with you
when i study and then work out
let's do it look at these
it looks just like your edgar
no nose on this one i like it
[Music]
i'm going to
get my car
out of the car one it's a little scary
to ride a bike here i'm not gonna lie
a lot of people ride on the sidewalk
here i think that's the most common way
but
you are allowed to ride on the left lane
anywhere
and honestly it's just as scary as
riding on the sidewalk
i think
in any other country you can't really
ride on the sidewalk where people are so
used to moving out of the way here that
somehow it works i'll try and show you
what i mean
all right let's see there you go
see there's so many ways where i'm like
coming up on someone
and i think there's no way they see me
i'm gonna have to stop and then somehow
they just move out of the way and i'm
like how all right let's test it test
the theory
it works
it's okay
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're heading up north
we stopped for lunch and then we got
stuck in traffic but now we're finally
moving so we're getting there we're
gonna try a supercharger on the way but
yeah we're going to the sprinter away
onsen because it's our anniversary
you look gorgeous
that's such a big brain too i love your
brain
i'll say it back
[Music]
this feels so odd i don't know why i
never done it so
it's that easy huh
all right
i might say i got made this new bag i'm
super happy with it and
i can put my drink in
oh hello
this is awesome
nice break place so we're
about one hour north of tokyo uh we
would have been fine with without
charging but i it to be safe so i don't
know if you pay or not
3b i'll go on s
you going
this is so pretty
i don't know if it shows through on
camera
damn that looks magical
it's already done i can't believe it
damn look at that view though
it's so dramatic now we gotta head off
to our
distant hour
[Music]
tesla marina
[Music]
they're playing the spirited away song
whoa
that was so cool
i was trying to catch it
it started so good we were listening to
the soundtrack
[Music]
we arrived so much later than we thought
oh
it's a lot cooler here
you probably can't even there you go fix
it
it's a little creepy i'm a little
creeped out are you crazy
why am i creeped out
you're going through
i kind of want to go around
okay
this looks lovely
now then get that check out our room
we're gonna
have some dinner now it's
8 o'clock almost so yeah we should get
going i'm hungry i'll probably put on a
shirt actually
i'll sleep there yeah damn that's a big
bed i didn't realize
that was a long trip
have a set meal i didn't know we had it
i thought i did something else
uh which means a lot of food
this
is bubbly soy sauce
you put it on
i probably put too much hmm
we survived another
course meal in japan that was delicious
the thing is i was trying to avoid this
because i don't i know
you know we don't eat that much and they
give you so much food and then what
ended up being i ordered that and more
food
i can wear a smackful but now i'm going
to change it to
look at that
there we go i love this outfit i look so
sweet
we got the turtle socks
[Music]
we found the tunnel
so
this tunnel connects the old and the
neuro ryokan wow it's old
that's fantastic
according to marzia it's built in the
1600s
wow
maybe the oldest piece at least
it's so hot
it's the first onsen in forever
we can't go usually because we have
tattoos but we have a private one so
it's okay
that's the end of this
bye bye see you tomorrow bye bye